[Musik]
schön dass sie wieder dabei sind beim
militär des jahres wir zeichnen ja die
angehörigen des österreichischen
bundesheeres aus für besondere
leistungen in vier kategorien und in der
sonderkategorie ich für die miliz in
dieser folge dreht sich alles um die
einheit des jahres hier sind die
nominierten einheiten im überblick in
alphabetischer reihenfolge
nominiert als einheit des jahres sind
das referat bio detektion hygiene und
mikrobiologie das bio probenahmen und
die masken prüfstelle stehen seit beginn
der kogit 19 krise im dauereinsatz
rund 6500 pcr tests werden durchgeführt
und 8500 schutzmasken auf mängel
getestet ebenfalls im zuge der gofit 19
krise fertig das produktionsteam mnm
rund 139.000 stück mund nasen masken an
25 prozent davon werden in der heeres
bekleidungs anstalt brunn am gebirge
gefertigt ein junger flugschüler muss
aufgrund extrem schlechter
wetterbedingungen von zeltweg nach
innsbruck umgeleitet werden
trotz widriger umstände kann das
military control center in
zusammenarbeit mit den zivilen stellen
eine sichere landung sicherstellt
welche der nominierten einheiten einheit
des jahres wird das geheimnis lüftet nun
der chef des generalstabs general robert
bringt meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
leisten an 365 tagen im jahr im in und
ausland hervorragende arbeit besonders
gefordert sind sie seit dem ausbruch der
kogit pandemie denn es müsse sowohl die
einsatzbereitschaft im inland als auch
die friedens unterstützenden operationen
im ausland aufrechterhalten werden
und das bei einem beträchtlich erhöhten
personaleinsatz
es ist daher notwendig ihnen den
bestmöglichen schutz vor einer
ansteckung zu bieten und dafür wird seit
monaten mit hochdruck gearbeitet
unsere einheit des jahres steht seit
ausbruch der pandemie an vorderster
front um zur eindämmung des corona virus
beizutragen
ich möchte sie nicht länger auf die
folter spannen und darf nun der
abteilung abc wesen und umwelt technik
mit dem referat bio detektion hygiene
und mikrobiologie den bio probenentnahme
team und der maske prüfstelle sehr
herzlich zum gewinn des awards in der
kategorie einheit des jahres gratulieren
sie hat seit februar im schichtdienst
durchgehend an detektion und
identifikation des virus gearbeitet
mittlerweile haben ihre mitarbeiter mehr
als 7000 bcr tests und rund 1500
antikörper des von soldatinnen und
soldaten ausgewertet als die infektion
in bosnien herzegowina und dem kosovo
rapide anstiegen wurden binnen 24
stunden je zwei teams in die einsatz
räume geschickt wo sie innerhalb eines
wochenendes rund 800 tests bei
streitkräften verschiedenster nationen
durchführten
aufgrund ergänzender testverfahren
galten die österreichischen tests als
besonders verlässlich
zusätzlich wurden rund 8500 schutzmasken
auf ihre verlässlichkeit geprüft und
mangelhafte aus dem verkehr gezogen
doch damit nicht genug es wird auch
intensiv an der implementierung eines
neuen anti gen test gearbeitet der
künftig vor ort eingesetzt werden kann
um das ergebnis binnen 30 minuten
liefert ohne dass dna einen labor
gebracht werden muss ein wichtiges
projekt das bei erfolg nicht nur die
testung unserer soldatinnen und soldaten
sondern auch die testung der
zivilbevölkerung erheblich erleichtern
wird
ich darf einen mitarbeiter die an diesen
projekten beteiligt waren und sind meine
herzlichsten glückwünsche zum gewinn des
awards in der kategorie einheit des
jahres aus spaß
großer freude und mit großem stolz
bereiche ich ihnen die auszeichnung
einheit des jahres 2020 gratulieren
recht herzlich
stellvertretend für alle ausgezeichneten
übernimmt der leiter der abteilung abc
wesen und umweltschutztechnik andreas
wimmer den award wie so manche abteilung
im bundesheer wird auch seine im comedia
extrem stark gefordert also ich hab
besonders zu beginn festgestellt dass
eine extrem hohe motivation der weise
die leute waren begeistert dabei und da
wirklich schwierigen bedingungen unter
großer belastung ihre arbeit zu
verrichten
natürlich wird es mit der zeit ein
schwieriges gibt dann so leichten
durchhänger und wenn man merkt dass die
leute irgendwo an ihre belastungsgrenzen
stoßen dann muss man dann versuchen
wieder zurück zu stecken und zu
entlasten wo es nur geht nach ausbruch
der pandemie ist eine der ersten
aufgaben die überprüfung der bereits
eingelangten machen wo wir feststellen
konnten dass eigentlich qualitativ
hochwertige masken auch nach 15 jahren
bei guter lagerung noch relativ
brauchbar waren also die wir weiter
empfehlen konnten wir ja damals eine
situation wirklich ein notstand war
wodurch die masken ausgegangen sind
dann in der nächsten phase kamen die
ersten masken dann aus china geliefert
da gab es große qualitätsprobleme und er
hat noch viele rück weisungen damals die
massen qualitätsprobleme sind bis heute
stark zurückgegangen
getestet wird aber nach wie vor
lückenlos dabei ist die form eines
gesichts von entscheidender bedeutung
unsere probanden müssen eine gewisse
gesichtsform haben es wird von jedem
probanden gesicht tiefe gesichts breite
und breite bestimmt das muss innerhalb
eines bestimmten rahmens seien nur sind
heute unsere gesichter etwas anderes als
den ihn in asien in fernost dadurch
geben sich nur probleme das masken team
china bestehen in ordnung sind bei uns
ein wie die greenfees facto aufweisen
[Musik]
andreas wimmer freut sich dass seine
kolleginnen und kollegen diesmal im
rampenlicht ganz vorne stehen ich denke
wir hatten einfach das glück dass das
die tätigkeiten die wir durchführen
jetzt benötigt werden
das muss man ganz offen sagen
auch wir freuen uns für die einheit des
jahres herzlichen glückwunsch
in der nächsten folge lüften das
geheimnis um den soldaten des jahres
machen sie es gut und bleiben sie gesund
[Musik]